are you looking for me to entertain you
again huh I don't have time for that
instead I'm establishing a mega Masjid
and daa center with Islam net I want you
to join this massive da Endeavor so
click the link below and donate
now how are you guys doing you would
have known that last week I made a video
about Elon Musk we went quite personal
about his family life and and repudiated
his claims bogus claims about Muslim
so-called Muslim grooming gangs Asian
grooming gangs Etc repudiating them
quite heavily from a sociological
perspective and ever since I have been
ravaging this man on Twitter through
engagements on his own
platform recently I have received a
threat through someone who knows Elon
Musk very well who is in contact with
Elon Musk documented public contact with
Elon Musk
and that threat was essentially a
blackmail Yes you heard it right I was
blackmailed that if I do not
stop attacking Elon Musk that I will be
framed for a crime I did not
commit now I'll be honest with you if
this is Elon Musk then this is the most
fragile weak thing that he could
potentially do come to a person Mr
freedom fre of speech who's attacking
him on his platform and come to that
person and try and threaten him through
blackmail if it is Elon Musk but this
threat went a bit further than that he
even said you will be gone you will be
gone so what is it a death threat now if
this is Elon Musk and I have to caveat
that because obviously through an
intermediary a documented intermediary
who does know who that is who I will not
be revealing right now you might asking
why are you not revealing it right now
I'm going to protect the identity of
this conduit of this intermediary I'm
going to protect the identity of hither
to what I shall refer to as the
informant henceforth I will refer to
this individual as the
informant but I've got all the receipts
oh yes and those receipts have been sent
to multiple sources with with the strict
instructions not to open them now so as
to breach the confidentiality of this
individual but that if I get arrested in
any country that this will be revealed
and or if we decide it's in the
Strategic interest of the Muslim
Community at large I have the discretion
to reveal this information at any point
in time so I put myself in a position of
control and decision- making at this
point in time
and that's why these kinds of bogus
threats whether the conduit or the
intermediary or the informant tried to
do it for their own purposes and or if
they did actually do it through
instruction from musk are nonsense and
you should know analyzing the profile of
one Muhammad hijab you should know that
actually Muslim people like myself who
believe in what I in will not be
deterred or perturbed or rattled by
threats like this if you know my profile
you know that I'm not going to be
rattled by things like this because we
believe in Allah and we believe in which
is the idea in of the Reliance of
God the Reliance and the trust of God
and that's the difference between me and
you Elon Musk I'm going to put it very
clearly what makes us Superior to what
you have
with which is money which you think will
grant you immortality as the Quran
mentions that he thinks that has money
has given him
immortality is that what I have unlike
what you have cannot be stripped away
from me possessions money Health can be
stripped away but faith and Iman cannot
be stripped away even if you amass all
of the armies of the world the American
Army NATO England this this that try and
threaten Muhammad hijab yes you could
take his life yes you could take you
could imprison him take his freedom but
you can never take his
faith why can't you never take his faith
because it's impossible from a logical
perspective to pry into my heart and to
take that Faith away from me so this is
the problem and the challenge that you
will find of threatening a person of
Faith especially the is Faith who
believes in martydom who believes in
seclusion with God who believes that so
long as they have faith in God that they
will be okay this is the problem with
the approach as we've seeing in Gaza of
thinking that you can kill children and
women and this and that and you can do
all
that and that that would mean that
you've won actually you've granted each
and every single one of those people in
the case of the Zionist entity
a gift the gift of martydom and so you
put them in a position of strength
you've made them win and likewise anyone
who wants to threaten me the public
knows now and this is an
issue of national integrity and what do
I mean by that Britain is meant to be a
sovereign country it is a quote unquote
liberal democracy if this is Elon
Musk which many would infer he has the
motive many would infer well he has
contact with this intermediary many
would infer to him if it is Elon Musk
doing these
things then this threatens the
sovereignty of this country it threatens
due process the entire legal process in
this country you've actually created if
this is you yeah one of the biggest
scandals recent history in Britain if it
turns out that there are receipts from
your end to the intermediary or there's
anything attaching you to the
intermediary then it's done for you Elon
Musk then you're finished Elon Musk and
or if members of the Muslim Community
cuz not just me it will start with
people like me but if any member of the
Muslim Community is arbitrarily removed
and put
into a prison on the bogus charge of
terrorism when on the record for
example they have no such um connection
and or if a scandal is attached to them
which is not in their character etc etc
now we will
know who has a hand in it now we will
know people are threatening us from
outside because they can't handle the
pressure that we're putting on them cuz
they're little narcissists because
they're insecure because they've they've
got an insatiable need for validation
because they have no faith they Hollow
from the inside they have no spiritual
strength and so everything is
about that piling up and amassing wealth
Etc that's their
life and so I will conclude with the
following that the public knows the
people know exactly what I've just said
to day and I will keep in my control and
through my discretion the receipts from
what I receive but I have a zero
tolerance policy to even a 1% threat to
even a possible threat yeah and you will
see that if anyone tries to threaten me
especially if they're using other people
to threaten me yeah that there will be a
response which will be swift it will be
legal and it will be consequential
t